it's so [ __ ] the wit to describe food
when they're like when they're like you
know it really tastes very interesting
to me like food doesn't taste
interesting period okay you know it
tastes you know it tastes good you know
it tastes great you know it tastes bad
you know what tastes spicy you know what
tastes bland you know it doesn't taste
interesting you know what it's
interesting look hmm that's very
interesting if you put something if you
put a [ __ ] bread crumb in your mouth
and you say god no that tastes very
interesting immediately you're out of my
club immediately you [ __ ]
and immediately all you do is you gotta
have an ego to say that's he's really
interesting oh yeah another one let me
let me describe to you the definition of
mouthfeel the physical sensations in the
mouth produced by a particular food ooh
this Cabernet has a dense tightly woven
mouthfeel with complex chili and velvety
tannins that's what the [ __ ]
definition sentence that was if you say
any of that stuff step back a little bit
because we're in the same room get in
that different room next to this room
good conch okay mmm has a very tightly
woven mouthfeel imagine being with
somebody at dinner imagine being on a
date and then hearing someone say that
has a really tightly woven mouthfeel
that wine has a really tightly woven
mouthfeel you know what a mouthfeel is
something too
described you can describe a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] oh that's a great mouthfeel
imagine getting your [ __ ] sucked and
being like wow what a mouthfeel dude
any guy getting a [ __ ] for the first
or second time with the girl that you're
with and you say oh what what a tightly
woven mouthfeel you're going to hell
you're going to hell above someone that
[ __ ] murdered someone well what a
mouth feel that by the way I didn't
realize this literally the most foreign
thing you can say oh wow this is a
really good mouthfeel when I eat these
pretzels with their arm with the outside
caramel on it wonderful mouthfeel it is
a wonderful mouthfeel the texture of the
title woven mouthfeel and Safari
you know a foreign porn guy took a
[ __ ] and was like oh that's a really
wonderful mouthfeel oh and here's the
thing that online the mystery of
mouthfeel what is it a [ __ ]
children's book say yeah hey turn around
see ya why is your nose facing the nose
mouthfeel dude I want to I want to train
all [ __ ] a decade and then enter the
Octagon as the fight or mouthfeel may be
the scariest should ever